warriors up ten to match up a Patrick  pebbly and Kevin Durant his job is to  frustrate trying to irritate trash talk  at the end of the day both guys have  tremendous respect for one another  Durant who parks out of Durant they're  both out they both had just thrown out  of the game double technicals which is  automatic because it's a second tech for  both  [Applause]  quick injection and maloi wasted no time  they've obviously been warned with that  first double technical  and we starting to get out of hand  between those two  Loran is done  for the night with 23 points Beverly's  done for the night  [Applause]  and this would have been just a tech on  the rant by going towards bevel who once  Bentley gets up and does his part and  that's both godless  and I would say this go against a game -  if I'm one of the referees I'm setting  it sold right away  [Music]  [Applause]  exactly that malloy not wasting time and  the right the right move  no question